So so far we've learned
that the AudioManager class
in the Android Framework allows
us to request audio focus
when we need to play audio.
And then it allows us to also
abandon audio focus afterwards.
We can also register
a listener to get notified
when the audio focus state changes.
Now this means that we'll
need an AudioManager
object instance of our activity so
that we can manage Audio Focus.
If we take a look at this audio
focus tutorial, the section labeled
Managing Audio Focus, it says that
we can use this line of code.
Context.getSystemService with
an input of AUDIO_SERVICE.
In order to get an instance
of Audio Manager class.
Now from this line of code, we see that
the Audio Manager is a system service.
Well this is the first time we've
heard about system services.
So there exist system services
that provide all apps
with common functionality.
So things like notification service,
or of the alarm manager service.
And there are some services
that allow us to access
hardware components on device such
as the location manager service.
But at the end of the day, a system
service is just a Java class and you can
interact with it by having an object
instance and then calling methods on it.